hallo herzlich willkommen in mailand
kochwelt heute gibt es ein sehr leckeres
rezept wir machen nämlich spaghetti mit
einer thunfisch tomatensoße und ich mag
die thunfisch tomatensoße richtig gern
weil es einfach unglaublich schnell geht
und sie schmeckt halt richtig schön 48
bisschen liebe mit drin tomaten schmeckt
halt sehr frisch und ich bin auch gar
nicht so viele zutaten ich hab sie
meistens immer zu hause also ich das
auch ein rezept was wir immer gerne
machen wenn wir einfach nicht einkaufen
waren und einfach aus der vorratskammer
uns die sachen holen und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal die zutaten als ich
brauche ein bisschen olivenöl
da habe ich jetzt schon etwa zwei
esslöffel in einer pfanne das wird auch
gleich heiß gemacht eine kleine treppe
knoblauchzehe ich brauche etwa zwei
esslöffel tomatenmark hier habe ich eine
dose tomaten das sind so gestückelt
also man sieht es auch dann brauche ich
eine dose thunfisch im eigenen saft
da habe ich jetzt auch den eigenen saft
mit dabei hier brauche ich noch ein paar
oliven da habe ich jetzt die ohne stein
dass ihr das ein paar paprikas mit drin
können wir auch mit dazu nehmen und mal
spaghetti ist natürlich und hier noch
ein paar gewürze herrscht zucker salz
pfeffer oregano und chili ich habe mich
eingeklemmt wenn die leute sich immer
fragen wie die reinkommen
die werden mich da rein gemacht
die paprika oliven reinkommt es wird
alles mit handgemachter in der türkei
wird es gemacht wird es zeigen wir euch
mal wie man dabei helfen im urlaub ich
schneide meine zwiebel in feine würfel
seit ich nur eben ein gutes metern
ausgelegt und jetzt habe ich so ein
stumpfes anatol na toll ich hunde kurzem
ein neues
und dann auch die knoblauchzehen fein
hacken wenn ihr es nicht so gern mit
viel knoblauch geschmack wollt könnt ihr
das auch einfach nur halbieren mit dem
die pfanne legen und später wieder
herausfischen
aber mir war es jetzt ganz mit rein
kommt als feine scheiben aber ich nenne
es nur die hälfte
server
ich glaube jetzt schon drei mal
geschnitten halt du jesu christi pfanne
heiß werden und jetzt gebe ich das
teilte jetzt bitte auch mittlere stufe
runter schalten damit die zwiebeln jetzt
nicht verbrennen
dazu führen wir das schön und sprachen
die zwiebeln glasig heißt halbdunkel
braten sondern die werden außer bisschen
heller sehen wir auch gleich werden
schön weich dann gehen wir gleich wenn
es soweit ist es noch zwei minuten
dann kommt gleiches privaten markt mit
treiben und ich setze in der zeit schon
minute was auch jetzt gebe ich das
tomatenmark mehr dazu findet übrigens
bald praktisch in dem glas weil ich kann
das glas verschraubt und weiß immer ganz
genau wie viele tomaten hopkins wird hat
schlecht weil hat kein sauerstoff kann
praktisch so traten wir jetzt ein
bisschen mit sonne minute
dann gebe ich jetzt die gehackten
tomaten mit ein und löscht das so
bisschen damit ab jetzt lassen wir das
erst einmal aufkochen
setzt euch fast verschüttet ich gebe
auch den zucker gleich mit der 1
lassen wir das jetzt schön aufkochen und
danach kommen die restlichen gehört zum
bistum verschmitzt
der thunfisch
und ich lösche das ganze jetzt noch mit
bisschen wasser ab also ich fühle dass
ein bisschen auf gras ein halbes glas
voll also 100 milliliter murat denkt wir
dann alles andere als koch aufkochen und
ich kann jetzt schon mal würzen
also kommt bei mir immer mit rein net so
viel wegen sanierung dann etwas salz
salzgitter sehr sparsam weil ihr der
thunfisch schon genug würze hat und ich
gebe gleich noch oliven mitteilung die
sind ja auch salze genau das ist nämlich
das was oftmals macht man versalzte
schmeckt alles noch gar nicht gebaut ist
oregano hat zum teelöffel voll und jetzt
bist fa
und jetzt werden es gleich wieder
aufgekocht habe ich gleich den ton
fischer es gibt leute die machen ihre
soße mit mit kitschig aber ganz
schrecklich jan zulauf ist geht für
heads up geht gar nicht also klar ist
ich auch mal gerne pommes und ketchup
weil ich weiß dass canon hat so aber nur
mit ketchup ich gedacht jetzt hole fisch
mit rein und es kann jetzt ein bisschen
vor sich hin köcheln und ich kann in der
zeit nämlich schon meine olive nehmen
und die in feine ringe schneiden
die oliven die kommen aus und putzer
okay und wie gesagt diese wiese paprikas
oder twin sie werden wirklich mit hand
rein gemacht also ich fast unglaublich
findet im glauben ist eine kleine olive
und wir werden dieses jahr vielleicht
noch nach usa gehen und werden das mal
vorstellen wie das gemacht wird werden
wir werden wenig schockiert also mich
sehr schockiert erstaunt erstaunt
schockiert klingt so negativ
aber dann so richtig lecker rollen also
grüne oliven mag ich ganz gern weil die
halt zufällig sind
auch schwarzer würde jetzt noch gut
reinpassen auch weg da gibt es ja
wirklich 1000 verschiedene versorgt
die eine schützte viel
das eigentlich nach kuranyi aber bei
olive finde ich darf meine ausnahme
machen die dafür darf man schon volle
pulle und jetzt gebe ich dir leben hier
auch direkt mit rein
wieso sich auch gleich fertig als ich
kann im prinzip das nudelwasser jetzt
fertig aufkochen lassen und die nudeln
gleich abkochen
da schalte ich jetzt dein herz bisschen
runter weiter soße damit es eben so ganz
langsam mit nur noch kocht und dann darf
das so etwa 5 minuten kochen
und ich glaube fest an klopp wir sind
fertig nun richtig schnell das rezept
die ganze ganze nudeln raus
wie kann man nur nudeln essen jetzt es
heute auch noch gern überklebt sie noch
sehen
schnell aufkochen und dann geht es
gleich weiter
und jetzt haben wir innerhalb von
ungefähr 15 minuten unser leckeres essen
gekocht
also dass ich auch mal was wenn ihr nach
der arbeit nach hause kommt oder nach
der schule keine zeit und keine lust
abzukochen
dann könnte ganz schnell dieses rezept
machen morattis geht jetzt eine kleine
portion weil wir haben eben eigentlich
schon bissl was gegessen
eine leckere suppe zur vorspeise und
eigentlich eine show pappsatt ja noch
was essen wir gehen doch gleich wo wir
jetzt hingehen das gucken wir uns in
anarchie parmesankäse drüber und murat
du kannst gleich probieren
als deine migration
ich mag das auf das ist schon so ein
frisch geriebener käse ich mag keine
zeit in kasan zur frisch gerät muss auf
jeden fall sein so aus der dose das
schmeckt ja ich soll auch sagen dass des
papas lieblingspaar mechanisch seiner
form ihres lieblings paar das mag schon
ein bisschen
ich glaube das einzige kind was auch
parmesan käse am stück mit ihrem
kindergarten nimmt und aus dem calcium
mit auch meines teams gesagt ja so ein
esslöffel paris entdeckt den
kalziumgehalt eines kindes für den
ganzen tag ein löffel mit calcium
glaubst du decken ihn wieder ein löffel
parmesan oder zehn menschen getötet
rezept gerne nachlesen auf cds - blog.de
und wir sehen uns dann einfach beim
nächsten mal wieder ruhig bist du ich
deshalb absagen
ich hab's rose drauf